vous avez été martine carrillon-couvreur
députés de l'opposition vous allez être
député de majorité pour vous c'est
qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils commencent
maintenant
écouter à partir de demain eh bien nous
allons nous mettre au travail
nous attendons ce moment depuis dix ans
alors ce qui me concerne puisque j'ai
siégé deux mandats dans l'opposition et
je vais évidemment être très attentive à
apporter les réponses qui nous sont
demandés depuis tant de moi et nous
l'avons vu l'expression du 6 mai vient
d'être amplifié un peu partout et j'en
suis très heureuse est ce que ça veut
dire aussi que la voie de la nièvre sera
plus audible
bien sûr la voie de la nièvre va compter
encore plus cette fois ci nous allons
pouvoir d'ailleurs nous l'avons déjà
fait nous allons pouvoir nous rendre
chez les ministres qui vont nous aider à
porter des dossiers pour lesquels nous
les avons sollicités nous étions déjà il
ya la semaine dernière dans un ministère
pour un dossier nivernais important il y
en a d'autres qui sont prêts et dès la
semaine prochaine et les jours qui
suivront bien sûr nous allons faire
entendre la voix de la nièvre